hi guys those of you that have been
subscribed to me for a while you know
that I love tech and I love going to any
sort of event that i can so i recently
went to Brighton Mini Maker Faire which
is basically a fair follows makers
makers of all sorts from techie makers
to even just your basic crafts and DIY
makers and it was just so much fun to
see them all under one roof everyone was
so creative individual and unique in
their own a wacky maker e way there was
loads of things from a light sense that
i could not help but dance to to a
unicorn that was voice controlled and if
you've said unicorn magic it pooped
bubbles there were kids running around
exclaiming it's pooping bubbles and that
was pretty much my reaction as well it
was amazing there's also places for you
to get involved and make your own things
like there was knitting programming to
make you from flashing badges that was
even live coding with sonic PI coding
some music but this time was a little
bit different because I not only
experienced it as a kind of audience
viewer having fun person I always also a
person behind the scenes because I had
my own little school some of you may
know that I went to an art hackathon not
too long ago and met some really
talented individuals and together we
bought a tech kind of artsy sculpture to
life called emo tea and that was what we
were showing at Brighton Mini Maker
Faire for those of you don't know what a
motor years it's basically a artistic
sculpture that represents the emotions
of the Twitterverse so it pulls in
tweets and refreshes them every three to
five seconds
and gets keywords from each of those
tweets and puts them in buckets of
emotions I guess there's happy sad
afraid surprised and angry think of
inside out kind of like that but we made
it before inside out okay we didn't do
that because of the film although it was
awesome though it was kind of like that
film anyway it is displayed on a monitor
that shows you colored rectangles which
are linked to the emotions and they
change width depending on how much
emotions felt within those key words
from the tweets that have been pulled in
at that very moment I'm trying my best
to explain is okay and then we also use
audio as well so you feel like you're
immersed in what the emotions of Twitter
are displaying to you a variety this
very second and it's very entrancing
actually so because we wanted to make
this a really engaging experience and
just fun for everyone we wanted to
really black out the surroundings and
have you focus on a motor at what it's
telling you so we got help from James
and he has a YouTube channel he is a
carpenter and a Magic Man of wood pneus
and I'll put his description in the link
below he helped us make this really big
black box for you to stick your head in
and really experience the mozy and it
was very pretty empowering a black box
around London to Brighton because
everyone's just like what's in box I
should quickly say a huge thank you to
some of the emoji team who helped me set
up the weekend Catherine Milton and
Bauer you guys are awesome i'm going to
put their link to the description below
so you can have a look at who they are
it was just an amazing experience seeing
how other people react to something that
you've had a hand in making seeing how
excited they are when they came out of
our black box and also how nervous they
were before they went in there and then
how some people were bouncing ideas off
of us telling us what might have made it
better what they really liked about it
what they didn't so much like about it
and just having a really good talk about
it and not only our project but everyone
else's project as well there were people
of all ages even
very small kids just getting so involved
in making things getting hands-on and
also understanding technology they
understand it so fast as well it's a
really really smile it was just an
amazing day just follow fun really yeah
full of fun so if you ever get a chance
to go to make it fair i would say go do
it it's really fun if you want to find
out more about a multi please look in
the description below I made a webpage
for it and that's got links to other
articles about it and there's a video on
it as well there's also some useful
links on the website that link to the
article on where it was made from but
also for you to see whether there's any
kind of tech communities around you that
you can get involved in and have fun
with anyway I hope you have a lovely day
or evening I I'm so excited and i just
can't hide it better than that 11 oh no
no